TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for "The Developer Show."
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
Wide color photography
is coming to Android,
so it's time to get
your applications
wide-color-gamut-ready.
This article can
help you with that
by showing you how to
test your application,
and giving you the steps you
need to take to be ready.
The link is in the
description below.
You can now access Google
Groups audit logs right
from within Cloud audit logs.
This opt-in feature
can help you use
Google Groups to manage your
organization's data access.
Links to get started
are on the post.
Google Kubernetes Engine is
a managed Kubernetes service
that puts security, reliability,
and ease of use first.
Check out this post for all the
updates on what's new with GKE,
including release
channels, Windows Server
containers in rapid channel,
and Stackdriver Kubernetes
Engine monitoring.
Google and Binomial
have partnered
to open source the
Basis Universal Texture
Codec to improve the performance
of transmitting images
on the web and within desktop
and mobile applications
while maintaining
GPU efficiency.
Now the basis universal texture
format is similar in size
to JPEG on storage, but
six to eight times smaller
than JPEG on GPU.
More info and a link to
the GitHub are on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
By the way, did you know there's
a smudge in your teleprompter?
It's fine.
I just want you to know.